oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui oh là là que je lève cette émission
ce soir on n'a jamais été aussi nombreux
autodata ça veut dire que sur cette
émission je peux vous le dire on perd de
l'oseille idées claires il faut le
savoir on l'a dans la tête spécialistes
ne vous le dit matthieu delormeau
non je vous ai pas appelé sera bizarre
je vous le dit bertrand chamerois il est
autour de la table ça va ça va gilles
verdez sympa sympa erika moulet en fait
je vais prononcer un mot dans un instant
et aux mots clés erika moulet sera
persuadé qu'il y aura un film porno
derrière vous ne trouvez pas un petit
peu coquin aujourd'hui tu vous qu'ils y
adhèrent
j'étais content ou pas cyril un oui un
problème de ce qui se passe il faut que
vous veniez ici parce que là il ya
quelque chose qui se passe que les gens
ne doivent pas voir
excusez moi mesdames et messieurs y ait
un problème je vais reprendre l'antenne
pendant quelques instants
il y as derrière grossir il des gens
d'ici copule
il n'était pas dans la jungle au nom tu
as la peau sucre est à huy très sucrée
mais ferme et [ __ ] l'instant bien
touche pas à mon pote
les tigres n'ont mystifie gilles tosques
la celtika taxage ilona du citron on a
du cran on a du cran a bien voulu qu'il
est en forme
oui tout va bien oui je vais fat32 ouais
ça vous voulez peut-être 1,9 avant de
démarrer mais elle a reconnu la poule il
a reconnu la poule
il a dans un ballon
[Applaudissements]
et
elle
non
m
bah j'ai laissé mon empreinte est grand
en arabe sa basse ariège
b day
et c'est à baie des ha
on parlera de koh lanta koh lanta qui
était en pleine jungle à l'agression par
les associations
[Applaudissements]
non
ça va vous et vous avez vu des stars aux
samoa
[Musique]
c'est un mois
lettre ma star
[Rires]
pour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
gbagbo
[Musique]